hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
i uh just reviewed the uh powered mod
ma speaker powered monitor from uh
adam uh called the a5x i've got the
written review on audio science review
website but i thought i'd do a video
overview of it
also and uh maybe i can explain things a
little bit more
this is like typical studio monitors got
amplification
in it it's a bit expensive for
this size speakers 500 each so a pair of
these would cost a thousand dollars
one nice thing is that it has a volume
control in front
which a lot of pro monitors don't have
and assume that you have an upstream
volume control which i do and many other
people do but if you're using them as
desktop computer speakers
and you don't have a preamp or some
other method of changing volume
it's nice to have this and a cool little
thing is that it's got a cable that
attaches the two speakers together
so you can use one volume control and
control the volume on both
much like other uh probe monitors you
can
set the sensitivity of the input and
also the treble and bass boost you can
adjust
i didn't adjust any of them i usually
don't and left them as default the
bass and treble the sensitivity i did it
just for testing
on that but otherwise everything's the
same it's a very heavy speaker
despite his size you can see it back
here
see if i mean struggling i think it's
got old school
class a b
amplifiers in it a linear power supply i
can tell that because the backside
actually gets warm not super hot but it
gets warm
um modern uh monitor the wild switch to
uh class d amplifiers which are more
efficient uh drawback and a lot of them
is that they hiss
through the tweeter this is uh this one
does not have a hiss that i
that i could detect at least with my
year close to the twitter
so that's a major thing a lot of these
pro monitors are not usable
from that point of view if you sit too
close to them
so anyway you're here to see
our fancy measurements that i generate
with a clippable
near-field scanner i
set it up for a thousand measurements um
and generated about a
i don't know 700 uh uh i'm sorry
something fell down
um something like a 700
megabyte file so heck of a lot more than
somebody just sticking a microphone in
front of a
analyzer unfortunately i ran into a bug
after running this test for three and a
half hours
i measure run the analysis too longer
than it
crashed and took me all day today to run
additional tests and
found a bug and a simple work around and
and got it done
so those of you who think my job is
great uh just know that there's a lot
happens behind the scenes that you don't
see that doesn't get published but the
drudgery
you know uh exists on that anyway
temperatures are getting warmer now
which is good this is in 65 degree
fahrenheit try to keep the temps above
60 degrees
some woofers underperformed a little bit
when you go below 60 degrees
um as far as uh measurements you need to
tell the system where on-axis is
and for that i just eyeball where this
amt tweeter is and i set the uh um
the uh microphone as the
reference point in the analysis software
uh clipping lnfs lets me move that
so occasionally i've done that where i
can move the axis anywhere in
computational uh portion of the analysis
of the measurement um so it's not
casting concrete but just know that
that's the center
the manual says the same thing it says
that that is the
you should point the twitter at you so
um we're going by what they say
um here's our response as usual we start
with this solid black line and the solid
black line if you just ignore this
trough in here
is actually fairly even there's a tiny
bit of treble boost and a tiny bit of
bass boost
but otherwise a very good response but
there's this v-notch in here with just
hard to take a high off of it it just
stands way out and it's quite
deep probably seven or eight db in here
and then a couple of resonances on each
side of it
where does that come from uh pretty
simple i
make a measurement by sticking the
microphone very close to each driver and
the port
this is the woofer in red the twitter is
in blue
by the way ignore the fact that twitter
keeps showing this is actually the
woofer response
shows up even though i have the twitter
the microphone from twitter
the key thing in here is the orange line
the orange line we can see that is the
port
this is the part of it that we want to
contribute
what we don't want is that it goes down
here and all of a sudden it starts to
get louder and louder and louder and
peaks and goes down
this is actually a resonance inside the
cabinet that
just if you just excite the cabinet at
that frequency and since the ports are
in the front
it jets out and instantly combines with
the woofer
and it combines with the woofer as the
woofer response is declining
and it's out of phase and because it's
out of phase it actually cancels in here
rather than add and you can see that
cancellation and just a massive v in
here
um the good news is that it's very
narrow it's it's uh
the 1.1 kilohertz over here and this is
one kilohertz so
it's about two 300 hertz wide and you
really got to get unlucky with some
musical note to hit this and as i've
explained in my last video with
our hearing bandwidth we don't have a
band with this sharp in here so likely
your ears averaging part of these peaks
and this trough you're not hearing
exactly this trough so the graph looks
worse than it is
it's a problem with these ports in the
front i often
see this issue i guess they put the port
in front so that you can stick the
speaker close to a wall i don't know why
it'd be an issue to have the speaker
close to a wall with the port in the
back but
people thought that oh gosh i can't do
that and i gotta have three feet behind
my speaker
so forces manufacturers stick important
front and it exaggerates this problem
this is on top of not mitigating it
there are other ways to mitigate it but
this port resonance thing seems to be
with us in many places here's a
waterfall
chart that basically shows your
frequency response and time
and uh i don't think i've ever seen
resonance stand out so clearly
in here we see our troughs in here and
then we see this thing just goes on like
a bell that's ringing
and uh so you know we have multiple
proofs we have three different
measurements all point to the same thing
and support each other
early reflections which is the floor and
ceiling and
back wall um they're very similar to the
on-axis for good or bad for good that we
want it to be similar which means that
reflections won't sound different than
the direct sound
bad is that that we have the v in here
and we have a little bit of directivity
error in here but there's a little bit
of a dip in here
so uh in general if you can avoid floor
bounce or if you have it on a desk
desk bounce it does you some good but
really is not a major cause of concern
if you had the speaker in far field
meaning stereo listening not on your
desk
we can model what that response could
typically look like and when we do that
lo and behold what we already know shows
up again which is we have this draft in
here
and this is the frequency response and
by the way above 10 kilohertz it droops
down because the
tweeter gets very directional as far as
distortion
at 86 db at one meter is actually
exceptionally good
um i have this 50 decibel
reference line and is well below that
even in bass which is impressive
now there's a trick up his sleeve you
know the reason this is so good is
because the frequency response is
dropping very quickly
so this speaker doesn't try to reproduce
low ba a deep bass
and as a result it doesn't have
distortion shooting way up here
if you turn it up distortion goes up but
still i'm not seeing it go crazy on some
speakers i see this line shoot up and
actually generate more distortion than
that you put in
over 100 distortion and you can see the
same thing as a ratio this is absolute
amount of
ratio we can see that these things start
to uh
you know become uncomfortable anything
less than 0.5
percentage in here is extremely good so
you know this is a little bit
above that but still very good if we
look at the beam width which means that
we take a constant amplitude
and and we plot what that looks like
where you get 6 db drop-off around the
speaker we see that it's very well
controlled
between about 900 hertz and about eight
or nine killers
after that the twitter starts to beam
this beam gets narrow
which means that if you don't have those
two uh speakers pointed at you and you
move to the left and right you're gonna
see here a drop-off in extreme highs
how good your hearing is up there it's
only you know
but uh for to hear the best sound you
really need to have this point of that
you're
at your ear which means you get it over
here you get this response
you still have 20 30 degrees you can go
and still not lose much but above that
you will
uh same plot if we plotted with the
fancy
color mapping we see it over here uh
this
you know this is our trough that we had
the port cancellation stands out
otherwise this is the even side and then
you can see how it narrows down and gets
much quieter
uh blue colors and green colors are
rather quiet
so if you you know where if you have it
like straight out and you're listening
at an angle you're up here and you're
losing a ton of highs so
don't do that excuse me um vertical
directivity which means this was
horizontal so that means we're going 180
degrees left
and right this one is going up and down
and up and down actually fairly good
usually we have these two eyes in here
and many times they're very close to our
reference
twitter line and which means that you
got to really
have the speaker pointing directly at
your ears here you can go 20 degrees
above 20 degrees
below so for my testing i had to point
it at my ear but if you
put them flat and you're a little bit
above them a little bit below them
still should be fine i uh
powered them up on my desk for all these
powered monitors i do near field
listening tests uh
basically where i'm sitting right now
you can't see it but on my right here
i have a spot where i put the speaker
and the sound was just fine i mean it
just
was low distortion clean and
it played as loud as i could tolerate
and i
turned things off and the reason it
could get so loud
is because it's amplification is
powerful it's not some cheesy little amp
in there
and also it doesn't try to apply deep
bass and
while it gets super loud you don't feel
a sensational bass so you need a
subwoofer
if you want that kind of bass for
computer use
typical desktop use there's plenty of
bass but
don't fool yourself this is not a
speaker that's going to
play anything in sub bass i have a large
library of those tracks when i played
them
it was as if they were not there the sub
bass i mean it was just very very faint
sounds
so uh what does it add up to we just
have one flaw there
in that directivity and by the way it
was so minor that i did not try to eq it
even it
is so narrow i'm not sure it needs eq
anyway as i said this little peaked on
each end i didn't feel that it needed
any equalization so out of box is
fine but you know it's got this design
error
and for 500 dollars for a
you know small speaker like this um
you know you're paying a premium and you
sort of want perfection so i like it i
recommend it
but i'm not blown away by it because of
that one flaw if that flaw wasn't there
i'd say wow this is great
and also the fact that it doesn't apply
a deep base
but you know adam's a company that's
competently
like competently designed speakers and
any shows in here so
definitely recommend it uh no that
doesn't have any hiss which is a big
deal
and uh you now have to go and and decide
whether this is
uh you know something you want to buy
relative to others i certainly blows
away a lot
of passive speakers that by the way you
need a separate amp form and everything
else
uh this is all optimized to have
extremely good response
okay hope you got something out of this
review
see you in a future one bye-bye